hand-in-hand with the UK Prime Minister
u.s. President Donald Trump presented a
picture of unity after talks with Teresa
May at her country residence
he said he back whatever brexit trade
policy her government wants to pursue
give our relationship in terms of grade
the highest level of specials once the
brexit process is concluded and perhaps
the UK has left the EU I don't know what
they're gonna do but whatever you do is
okay with me that's your decision
whatever you're gonna do is okay with us
just make sure we can trade together
that's all that matters and with that
the president completely backtracked on
comments published just hours earlier in
a UK tabloid in an explosive interview
Trump trashed the Prime Minister's
brexit plan I would have done it much
differently I actually told Teresa they
had to do it but she didn't agree with
she didn't listen to me no but it'll
definitely affect trade with the United
States unfortunately in a negative way
the interview in which Trump also
criticized Teresa made by praising her
rival the former Foreign Secretary Boris
Johnson added fuel to the fire in
response to the u.s. president's visit
tens of thousands marched in London to
protest his presence on UK soil
I just find it really really
embarrassing I think over the last kind
of a couple of weeks we've had a big
sense of national pride and to resumes
just completely ruining it holding hands
with him again debating races to the
treaty and he's a cheat he's a thief but
the president's trip has been
choreographed so that he largely avoids
coming face to face with protestors and
their balloon depicting him as a giant
baby